Let's get into audience questions for the week.
I've been getting a lot of these types
of questions which essentially amount to
what is the impact of Donald Trump having Corona
virus on the presidential race? Does it help him?
Does it hurt him? What about a sympathy
vote? What about people who will see him
as getting the virus because he's irresponsible?
So we have to divide this into a few different
categories of people and a few different
scenarios. So let's first get out of the way,
the more sort of legalistic scenarios. If Trump
were to become very sick again and again, we don't
yet know what the course of his disease will be
this week. Doctors have been saying he's doing
great by the time you watch this or listen to this
clip. He may be doing poorly. It's just all so
dishonest and so erratic that we don't know. But
if Trump gets very sick, ends up on a ventilator.
Mike Pence becomes acting president. Does Mike
Pence become the top of the ticket? Who are people
really voting for? Very impossible to predict
how it would change the dynamic of the race.
But my guess would be that might almost help the
Republican ticket in that the idea of a steadier
person coming in Pence might be more appealing
to some Republicans than reelecting Donald
Trump. But it's very unpredictable. If Trump
were to die before the election, we are in
outlandish, marginal territory. And who
knows what would happen? But assuming that
Donald Trump remains alive and it does not become
incapacitated due to a resurgence of the virus,
my instinct is that anybody who would vote
based on whether their candidate gets the
virus is already voting for Donald Trump. What
I mean by that is anybody who would say, well,
if you get the virus, you're weak. Those people
are already voting for Donald Trump and they're
going to continue voting for Donald Trump. If you
vote based on policy and you're concerned about
the handling of coronavirus. You're almost
certainly already voting for Joe Biden. The
only way in which Trump's corona virus case
would affect voters, in my mind, would be
that Trump getting the virus in addition
to Chris Chris, the Kaley McEnany, Trump's
campaign manager, ho pick on and on and on. It
is part of the story not of individual contagion,
but of the mishandling of corona virus more
broadly by this administration, that they've
been so careless and reckless that while almost
no prominent Democrats have become infected,
all of these prominent Republicans, including
people around Trump, it's the needle. It's
the straw that breaks the camel's back, so to
speak, in terms of the mishandling of the virus.
Those are people who might be inclined to
vote for Biden or at least not for Trump.
As a result. But it's sort of like an
indirect effect of Trump getting the virus.
Overall, it seems bad for Trump,
although, again, it's all so erratic.
But it seems as though Donald Trump plans to be
at the second debate. It seems as though Donald
Trump is relatively recovering, although much of
it may be driven by steroids that he's on, which
can create, you know, feelings of euphoria or a
feeling great. It appears as though the debate,
the postdebate post diagnosis polls we are
getting are really, really bad for Donald
Trump. And my bottom line assessment is it's
not good for Trump. It may not be that bad,
but the Corona virus episode is not
good for Trump. Next question, today's.